[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot it
has been a while but we are back with
our Q&A episode after our episode two
weeks ago on hallo destiny and Bungie
I'm like my hardy here with Jake Decker
what's up and destiny too as of this
video is out we've been playing a lot of
it so far nothing but pleasant things to
say for the most part especially
compared to the first game I saw you
know the video that we last did was more
you know like some of the influence that
Bungie has had on shooters and the video
game industry in general and like the
Xbox might not even exist today as it is
if it wasn't for Halo kind of saving it
back in the day we moved from Mac over
to to Microsoft but we really want to
dive into that kind of a brief history
of Bungie and where they're at now and
what they're doing with destiny too and
how that kind of is spawned from what
they did with Halo and we got a few
questions we want to get to might as
well just jump right into that first off
one of the comments that I saw that was
prevailing throughout the YouTube
section was that like it sucks the halo
isn't as good now 343 is screwing up
halo the franchise in general I don't
love Halo 4 I like Halo 5 more I think
it's still I think it's a a good game
great in a lot of ways Halo 4 I thought
the campaign was kind of boring I
thought they did a good job of
introducing new enemies in the new world
but I will agree with a lot of people
saying I think Bungie understood what
made halo special more than 3 4 3 does
I'm the opposite I think I like to have
4 I like Taylor for more than I liked
Halo 5 but yeah I agree overall that I
think Bungie definitely understood what
Halo was more than 3 4 3 does but I mean
I still enjoy what 343 has been making
like I've been having fun with it but
definitely like I will never be as hyped
as I was for Halo 2 or 3 or even like or
even reach oh yeah it's really hard to
reach regions which i think is not the
best but I think that is an underrated
Halo game oh yeah it's one of my
favorites my favorite in terms like
campaigns the first game multiplayer I'd
say 3 but I think overall halo 2 is my
favorite Halo game um I don't know a lot
of people in the comments are saying
their favorites and just editing this
video a couple weeks ago made me want to
play halo again I busted out the Master
Chief collection which you know
I left a sour taste our mounts after you
launch issues the servers and everything
when people just wanted to jump right
into multiplayer but I played a system
link like LAN party at my at my parents
house over vacation with some old high
school friends and that was like the
most fun I've had with games in a while
we do have a couple questions on again
to Jake I'll have you read the first one
okay monkey X move three five says
bungees marathon was also the very first
FPS game to include dual wielding and
rocket jumping alongside rise of the
Triad which released on the same day
yeah so I mean if you watch the last
episode I talked a lot about marathon
and how free look in games especially
like a mouse like we take it for granted
today be able to look 360 degrees around
you and up and down like and you know
like I'm two different axes
yeah marathon was the first game to have
complete free look in system shock you
had to toggle into it doom you can only
move side to side with your viewpoint
but yeah marathon also like introduced
rocket jumping and like they said dual
wielding I think rise of the Triad I
think after reading up it was December
21st 1994 marathon rides the Triad both
released in the same day and they're the
first game to have dual wielding which
is weird but yeah that became an
influence obviously on halo 2 halo 1 did
not have dual wielding and then halo 2
you could have the two different guns
like the SMG pistol combo was always
awesome the needler and SMG but yeah
like and then in Goldeneye you could
actually have two different guns if you
had the all guns cheat on you could do
AAA and then to go cycle backwards you
press Z and a and then a again you'd
have like the the club in one hand and
then the oh yeah I forgot yeah but
anyway yeah that's it's it's weird how
many small things Bungie did to
contribute to what shooters are today
and yeah I've went back to play a little
bit of marathon and that recently it was
like a year or two ago but it doesn't
hold up as well but yeah having free
look I can't imagine going back to the
original doom without that and just
being able to only look side to side via
it's a we take it for granted I have
your played marathon okay I wait that
one they brought to Xbox 360 right yes
yes I played that yeah yeah because I
remember a system shock you had to
actually like kind of toggle into the
the free look to move around and that
was kind of a pain that game was a
little slower pace than marathon though
so I don't think it mattered as much but
yeah so monkey X mu 3/5 thank you so
much for your comments on YouTube as
always we go through the comments every
episode to see which ones would be best
for Q&A I have one more today I wanted
to get to gray fox gray period fox on
youtube says I enjoyed destiny and I
hate to be that guy because I hated that
guy but now I'm all about warframe and
really feel disillusioned by how tight
bungees control of player customization
and experiences
I still enjoy destiny but wonder why
they can't let go of the reins and let
the players go wild I think the next
video should be a comparison of the
history of destiny against the history
of warframe and Digital Extremes
to touch on that first unfortunately we
probably have to be focusing more on
games coming out I know next episode
which we could probably actually tease
because I'm dead set on what we're gonna
do it's it's interesting cuz I mentioned
warframe in last episode I've never
gotten the chance to play it extensively
I probably played two hours which
obviously with a game like that isn't
that's nothing that's a drop in the
bucket but I it is it I did not like
destiny won as much as I thought I would
because that Bungie is kind of a control
freak with the progression and with the
time you spend in the game and how you
get rewards so far about ten hours into
destiny to actually have that as of this
video I'll have played much more but
when we're recording this I played about
ten hours and I'm not seeing that as
much and destiny to which is like
refreshing I think you're farther than
me Jake I don't maybe you could talk
more about that I am I finished the
campaign and I've probably I'm probably
like I don't know I'm light level 237
which I don't think they call it light
level any more power level you've got
like 130 on me yeah so I've I've played
quite a bit and I think one thing that I
noticed most of all is that there are a
ton of different diversions you can do
which all feed into your goal so it's
not like it's not like destiny one where
there's some things that the game didn't
quite tell you and you'd spend a lot of
time doing something or investing into a
piece of armor and or or a faction for
example you'll find out you're wasting
your time it seems like this does a much
better job at pointing you in the right
direction letting you kind of choose
what you want to do how you want to
progress and then on top of that there
is more customization although I don't
know if that's exactly what he was
talking about but you can like change
each individual piece of armor and then
you can buy you can buy I think that
real money but you can actually buy
skins for your guns and stuff so there
is a little bit more player creativity
and you can show your personality a bit
more which I think you can do quite a
bit in warframe I don't know if it's on
par with warframe because I haven't
played warframe but yeah it seems like
Bungie is definitely kind of given the
players more of the reins this time
around what do you think of the
one-time-use Armour shaders is it as big
of a deal as a lot of people are making
no I don't think it is I have you gotten
a lot of them so I didn't bother using
any of them for the first part because I
figured alright most this gear is
throwaway like I'm gonna use this for 10
minutes move on to something else so I
so I finally hit max level and I have a
pretty high light level I'm at the point
where I don't swap out armor every
couple minutes I get taken a while to
get that
so I finally started using the power
level Jake this is w-whatever and I have
so many shaders I have duplicates of a
lot of them as well I could see how if
you want like an exotic shader it could
be a pain trying to grind for those over
and over again even if they don't even
if there are exotic shaders to be honest
and you're committing when you when you
if you get one that you really like that
you seem more unique than the others
you're committing to like oh I want my
pants to look like this definitely sorry
first you can still preview so make sure
to do that before you use it
but I honestly I think once people get
to the end and realize that you're
getting I'm so frequently I don't think
it'll be as much of an issue but I so
thank you gray fox for the question any
tip I have one more overarching question
before we close out and maybe tease next
episode Jake do you think destiny 2 is
kind of like a big comeback for Bungie
cuz destiny sold really really well how
does a lot of players had a lot of
players probably up until last week it
was definitely like this cultural
phenomenon despite the fact that a lot
of people were down on it taking King
was a step in the right direction rise
of iron is kind of just plateauing but
do you think guessing - is kind of gives
us more hope that Bungie is going in the
right direction I thought I thought that
was taking King because I I
played a lot of the first destiny but I
really did not like it it was just kind
of a it was I just kept playing but I
was like why am I doing this
and I think right or taking King when
taking King came out I finally kind of
got more invested in I kind of
understood what I was doing I was
looking forward to grinding looking
forward to playing with friends
I think destiny too is a even bigger
step in the right direction I think it's
a fantastic game and I don't know I kind
of think Bungie kind of always knew what
they were doing to an extent I just feel
like they were jumping into some
uncharted waters with destiny one and it
sounds like there was a lot of
development issues and disagreements and
things got scrapped something there was
a lot it there was there was a lot at
play during destiny one that I feel like
with this do they finally figure out
what they're going for what they're
gonna do it and using what they learned
with taking King they kind of built on
that and made something very solid
someone on our live show it games not
the lobby the other day and the twitch
chat was saying it reminds them of
titanfall - hopefully the new
battlefront coming out these games that
are almost like what we wanted the first
games to be destiny - feels like it was
it's what closer to bungees vision that
we kind of wanted it to be I don't know
if I agree with that necessarily just
because the hype for destiny I was not
aligned but I thought there would be
tons of planets you could explore I
figured you'd take your spaceship also
like I didn't think I liked your
spaceship but I figured I figured
there'd be more discovery involved and
yes there was discovery and in this one
there's more discovery but it's still
very focused on that loot grind
first-person shooter action game yeah
and is good and I think now that my
expectations aren't set for what I was
hoping with destiny 1 I think I had like
destiny 2 a lot more but I don't know if
it's I don't know if it's quite the same
thing with Arab it's quite the same
situation that we had with battlefront
and
time's the height and fall yeah I'm
excited to play more of destiny too for
sure it just pulling me through like the
first game did not reminded me of taken
King I was like you know I'm still not
100% sold on it not just being a big
expansion but the more I play the more
I'm like oh this is actually a sequel
there's a lot of quality of life changes
there's a ton of new worlds to explore
the world themselves feel more vibrant
there's more to do these adventures are
really cool side quests that are not
just the other troll great the public
events a you can actually see them on
the map and when they're gonna happen
and then you have to go to a website to
see what's going on on the Moon or Mars
or whatnot the public events are also
like pretty cool boss fights too they're
not they're still bullets spongy like I
guess that's gonna happen in this game
but it they're more nuanced every time
I'm fighting them like these rituals
that you kind of interrupt that they get
pissed off about and then you have to
fight them a certain way but all-in-all
I think I think this is you know giving
me more hope I know like I knew Bungie
knew what they were doing but it seems
like they're making good on what they
wanted to do in the first place I
personally think but as always thank you
for submitting your questions on YouTube
your comments on YouTube we will be back
next week we are gonna be talking a lot
about Nintendo
we've been playing what we like we
played at this point we can say been
playing Metroid Samus Returns I don't
have like a review score but I
absolutely love that games fantastic
yeah so we're gonna be talking about a
lot of about Metroid this will go up a
couple days after Metroid releases on
the 3ds we're gonna be talking my Mario
Plus Rabbids we're gonna be talking
about breath of the wild we're gonna be
talking about the switch in general just
overall how Nintendo is just like
killing it this year and we'll be
talking about more about that next week
so in the meantime as always hit us up
on Twitter and Emma Hardy or Jakob deck
with two K's just if you have any
questions or comments about reboot and
we always love to do in these Q&A
episodes so keep commenting and letting
us know what you think of show or any
criticisms or questions that you might
have and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you